everybody I'm pleased to introduce Jerry
McManus today from Lamont Jerry got all
his degrees in Columbia University and
then did a postdoc in which Hall was
dilia OPO and Bill Kerry and stayed
there for about a decade longer and then
came back to Columbia and where he's now
a professor in the Mont Jerry is a poly
oceanographer and he spent quite some
time at sea
he studies mostly paleoclimate during
the quaternary and today he'll tell us
about Atlantic meridional overturning
circulation and rapid climate change
thank you thank you very much huggy
thank you all for being here when Hyatt
invited me she said that I would have an
hour and a half time slots for my talk
and I thought wow she must have been to
some of my aju presentations and I
probably could talk for an hour and a
half but I assure you I I don't plan to
but I I will I will therefore take the
luxury of of taking a minute to provide
just a little bit of context of my
connection to Yale that's how you'd
mentioned this I'm in my third stint at
Columbia I was an undergraduate I left I
came back as a PhD student I left and I
came back in each of those first two
times as an undergraduate I visited Yale
once as a graduate student
the very first talk that I gave outside
of Lamont was that Yale and of course
you already know that this is a carl
tarik Ian story
it was in a room much like this maybe
even this room and it was my first talk
outside Lamont as I mentioned so I was
somewhat nervous and I gave my talk and
for all indications
kalter ikan slept through it and then
raised his hand at the end and I thought
oh I know this old trick
you have your question ready before the
talk and then you can snooze for a while
and answer and instead Carl said now let
me get this straight and he proceeded to
give a synopsis of my talk that was much
clearer and maybe surprising to some of
you much more succinct than my ones and
so I think my first answer to my first
talk to my first question at my first
talk ever was yes although I may have
said yes sir because there was nothing
more I could ahead so I'm afraid I can't
I can't hold the promise that I'll be as
clear as that synopsis of my talk but
I've had some practice over the years so
what I'm going to show you is some great
stuff and if I don't do it justice
please feel free to stop me and ask a
question and I'll try to clarify ok the
work as almost always I'm going to be
showing others work and in this case
it's primarily graduate student Jean
Henry former graduate students Sharon
Hoffman and a former postdoc Louise Brad
Miller who I've been working with along
with a number of other really excellent
colleagues and many of us have spent
time at Columbia Lamont as it turns out
when I looked at this author list our
single overall connection is all to the
Woods Hole Oceanographic Institution
where we've all spend some time and I'll
start with this what I think of as awful
figure and it's awful not in the science
but only in the color scheme as I view
it and maybe I'll use this to introduce
two aspects that might not be familiar
to some of you in the audience one is
that like many pollution ographers paler
climatologists most of the time I'm
going to show time moving from your
right to your left not always so I'll
try to remind you when I switch back and
forth but mostly that's how I'm going to
present time and then I'm going to apply
the convention that warm is up and warm
is broadly defined if it's temperature
then it will be warm up but if it's co2
it will be high co2 up if it's methane
it will be methane high methane up when
it's the strength of the Atlantic
meridian or overturning circulation when
it's strong that will be up I'll try to
be consistent about that this figure
introduces the idea that during the last
ice age there was a bipolar contrast in
the behavior of the southern hemisphere
and the northern hemisphere and you can
see that in in almost any location here
but if you're not familiar with this the
place to look is in this pink shading
which are the cold stadia --ls
associated with the so called Henryk
event iceberg discharges I'll say a
little bit more about them but in a way
those are the coldest times in the
northern hemisphere and if you look more
or less carefully you'll see that there
are times where the southern hemisphere
was warming and at the end of them the
northern hemisphere warmed and that's
when the southern
began to cool and I'll get to my
punchline I think that we are providing
further evidence that this bipolar
contrast was driven by internal dynamics
by the ocean and atmosphere and I would
say largely by the overturning
circulation of the ocean moving heat
around the planet not shifting that the
mean temperature of the planet
don't be sorry I welcome the
interruption the argument that it's in
phase I think has to do with the fact
that the transitions in temperature
don't proceed at the same rate well
maybe I shouldn't put words in your
mouth wait where do you think would you
say that it's it's warm here and it's
warm here
the maximum the men are close to each
other that that's fair enough I'm going
to argue that they are close to each
other but they are not the same at the
very end of the talk I'm going to show
some unpublished data that come from the
waste divided ice core in Antarctica
which is an Antarctic ice core with
Greenland style resolution and and I'm
going to make the argument that although
you're right that it's warm here and
warm here what happens is that this
warms and almost immediately but not
immediately almost 200 years later the
south starts to cool that's the point
and and maybe they're certainly not
anti-phase that that's not the argument
that I'm making here so we can come back
and revisit that but at least the
contrast in the direction of warming and
cooling can be described as a bipolar
seesaw that there is a shift in that
cooling in the North is associated with
warming in the south and one means to
accomplish this in a computer model is
to flood the North Atlantic with fresh
water and this has been demonstrated
again and again in a wide range of
models it's not the only way to make it
happen but it's it's one way and the
ocean circulation that I'm talking about
is the large-scale sometimes called
thermohaline circulation that just
because of the accident of the shape of
the basins and the fact that there's
deep water formed in the North Atlantic
in the Atlantic Ocean it's largely
meridian oh so that on some scale
there's a net northward
of warm salty water that's balanced by a
deeper and somewhat colder water mass so
that's giving a heat transport northward
we know that that was different at times
in the past I'm going to argue that it
was different again and again and he
almost exact conjunction with that
bipolar evidence from ice cores but
before I get there I have to introduce a
few concepts I've talked already about
this Henryk event iceberg discharges
this is what they look like in terms of
evidence on the seafloor this is the
abundance of course detrital grains of
the rock all plateau in the North East
Atlantic that almost certainly can only
have arrived at these sites by drifting
ice and there are do chemical tracers in
them that indicate that they came from
North America not from Europe and what
you can see here is this is the benthic
oxygen isotope that tell us that this
was the descent into the last ice age
and here's the last glacial maximum and
then the deglaciation and you can see
that the amount of debris in this
sediment core doesn't increase
monotonically or in concert with the
amount of ice but is repeatedly episodic
that there are layers after layer of
debris
and the idea is that this is the debris
that we find on the seafloor but the
conceptual model is if it came from
icebergs those icebergs melted and in
that melting they would have lowered the
salinity at the sea surface therefore
stabilizing the water column diminishing
the likelihood of deep water formation
so that's the background context about
what might be going on in the North
Atlantic and now I'm going to present
evidence from in particular from a
single new long core recovered from the
Bermuda rise but it's going to be three
lines of evidence about the deep ocean
circulation the Bermuda rise is a
feature that sits here in the deep
Western North Atlantic because of
recirculation gyres it has a
tremendously high accumulation rate of
sediment on the seafloor and that allows
better resolution of time in the past
but it's also presented a problem
because it's too much sediment to
capture easily in standard quarry
technology the proxies that I'm going to
use our sedimentary burial fluxes in
particular the preservation of calcium
carbonate which is a building block of
micro fossils on the seafloor
but the burial on the seafloor of that
calcium carbonate a tool called
protactinium thorium ratio which is
based on the contrasting chemical
behavior of uranium and it's daughter
isotopes in the ocean and the third one
is the stable carbon isotope ratio in
benthic foraminifera that live on the
seafloor not within the mud
so before I get to the first proxy I
have to remind you that the Bermuda rise
is a deep location it sits at
four-and-a-half kilometers in the deep
western Pacific and you can see here in
this map of dissolved carbonate ion that
it's within this tongue of water that
spreads southward as North Atlantic deep
water and has a dissolved carbonate ion
concentration that's right around 100
micro moles per kilogram whereas water
spreading northward from the South have
lower dissolved co3 and that's relevant
to the preservation of calcium carbonate
on the sea floor because there is a
pressure effect on the preservation or
dissolution of calcium carbonate these
this particular line here is the
functional form of that pressure effect
so you can see that this is the
saturation horizon and that means that
concentrations that would fall to the
left of that would lead to increased
dissolution and concentrations that fall
to the right of this curve would lead to
an enhanced preservation and I think it
might be subtle but I think you can
recognize here this here to here is the
signature of that same North Atlantic
deep water where as waters that are
coming in from the South today at this
location at about 20 degrees south
they're below the calcite saturation so
they're not preserving waters they're
corrosive waters and I'm going to show
that in the North Atlantic that changed
through time
I'm also going to talk about
protactinium thorium and so at this site
map I'm just putting you in the context
of the global distribution of
protactinium thorium but I'll introduce
that proxy in a little greater detail
the core we're using is one of seven
that were taken as part of a cruise of
the United States only long coring
system which sadly is going away because
the ship that it's on is being retired
so I think possibly as I speak that
system is having its its last run in the
Atlantic but these are some of the best
cores that exist in the world for length
for quality for volume and preservation
of the sediment without coring artifact
and you can see of these there are
recognizable Wiggles in this density
profile as as measured on shipboard and
we chose to work on the core that had
the longest continuous section with by a
small amount the highest accumulation
rate and that means that we're looking
at the last large climate cycle
deposited in 30 meters of sediment on
the sea floor the benthic oxygen
isotopes that we use to tell us where we
are in time over this interval are quite
recognizable that they match well the
global record of oxygen isotopes that
show that here is the last glacial
maximum here is the current Holocene
interglacial here's the last peak
interglacial and here is the penultimate
glaciation and most of what i'm going to
talk about is this interval here
so this is work that bill curry and his
students at Woods Hole accomplished
before bill left for BIOS they measured
planktonic oxygen isotopes in every
centimeter of the upper 20 meters of
this core that is yes something like
20,000 analyses and from those
individual measurements a mean record
can be mapped out that follows the
Greenland ice core dellow 18 in the
upper most sediments Jean Henry a
student at Lamont has also measured in
detail the composition of all the
sediments and what you can see for the
last 20,000 years going back to the last
glacial maximum is that the detrital
composition and the calcium carbonate
largely trade off so the predominant
sediment is always detrital material
that's swept in from the continents and
then remobilize so it's very fine
material and then there's a mixture of
calcium carbonate the two of them trade
off but there is a third component of
biogenic opal so Jean did a great job on
this but it was a lot of work to measure
each of these samples and we were
looking for a way a more rapid way
possibly less invasive that would allow
us to get data from all of the core and
gene then turned to scanning XRF which
is x-ray fluorescence and he analyzed
the core by x-ray fluorescent at Woods
Hole and then use the calibration set of
his
on detailed measurements and this is
what the calcium carbonate content the
calibrated calcium carbonate content of
that this is the deep sea sediment core
and here again is Greenland and it turns
out to our eye at least that calcium
carbonate oscillations and oxygen
isotope oscillations occur in almost
one-to-one correspondence throughout
this cycle throughout the length of this
court and if we blow this up we can see
that the times of low calcium carbonate
content this is just a percentage are
the Henryk event intervals and high
calcium carbonate content are the warm
inter stadium over Greenland but what we
want to know is not the proportion of
calcium carbonate but its flux into the
sedimentary record and that flux can be
driven by biological productivity but
this is the Sargasso Sea
it's a subtropical gyre it's not
particularly productive place we think
that what controls burial here is the
preservation on the sea floor so we'd
like to know the burial flux is to get
an assessment of the proportion of
burial or preservation and the way to
get at that is to use a constant flux
proxy we know that uranium and its
daughter product thorium have very
contrasting behavior in in seawater
uranium is highly soluble and that means
that it has a long residence time in the
ocean on the order of hundreds of
thousands of years and it's because the
mixing time of the ocean is some very
few millennia that means that the ocean
is well mixed with respect to uranium
and that means that the decay
of uranium into two thorium at any one
location is known predictable and
relatively constant over the timescales
we're talking about thorium on the other
hand is essentially insoluble and its
residence time in the ocean at least in
the Atlantic Ocean of our shores is on
the order of a decade it's produced and
it's removed rapidly by absorption on to
settling particles so that means it's
accumulating on the seafloor at a
constant rate and in a schematic view
thorium is produced in the water column
and then scavenged by a reversible
exchange is the preferred model but it's
scavenged by adsorption and desorption
and then at sorption again on to
settling particles and when there's a
lot of sediment that thorium-232 'td and
when there's not so much sediment it's
not so diluted either way we can
normalize the settling flux of anything
accumulating on the seafloor now because
thorium is is present in the tribal
materials we have to make a correction
for the material washed in off the
continents and we can do that in two
ways we do it by measuring as a ratio
two so-called common thorium or 232
thorium or more directly by looking at
the decay chain of uranium 238 and 234
those isotopes occur in the Bermuda rise
at something of a constant ratio so the
two Corrections yield the same result
and this is what thorium-232 interval in
the last ice age this is all of the four
m230 in the sediment this is the excess
portion
portion that was absorbed from by
particles from the from the seawater and
when we invert for the settling flux of
particles across this number of
carbonate cycles you can see here that
there are changes in both the detrital
flux and then the calcium carbonate flux
I'll first show that the tryto flux
that's the predominant one right and
what you can see is at the increase of
each of these carbonate cycles there's a
spike in detrital flux and then it
declines a smaller one here another one
here a larger one here and it declines
the mass flux pattern of calcium
carbonate is somewhat different it tends
to spike at about the same time but it
stays high longer so in the end the
peaks in the calcium carbonate content
are driven by both but it's the increase
in flux of calcium carbonate that we're
interested in here this suggests that
across each of these events calcium
carbonate preservation at the sea floor
was at a maximum yes
it's everything it's the bulk sediment
the there there are variations in the
particle size and that's a function of
the abundance of form initial shells
which are sand size versus cockle is
which are silt sized but the calcium
carbonate yeah yes yes because in the
case to get the high resolution long
record that was generated by a remote
method that's x-ray fluorescence it
doesn't distinguish between those types
and and there's probably an important
story there but this holds here
so this is combining those figures now
and the carbonate percentage isn't here
but I want to make the point to you that
the peak in the detrital flux generally
coincides with the rise of the calcium
carbonate flux in the end I'm going to
interpret both of those things together
and that's why I said sediment fluxes
not just calcium carbonate flux we think
that across each of these intervals
calcium carbonate preservation became
better now that productivity increased
to this great extent preservation became
better to us that means that the
dissolved carbonate ion increased at 4.5
kilometers of the deep sea at those
times the detrital flux of fine-grained
2 rigidus material also increased and we
think each of these things is consistent
with a flushing into the deep ocean of
newly formed northern source water that
had higher carbonate ion as it does
today and remobilize
sediments we previously published the
most recent of these spikes and we
speculated then that it might be
remobilize detrital material or
something related to rising sea level
because it was during the d glaciation
and the rising sea level might have
remobilize sediments from the shelves
that can't be true here these are not
associated with those kind of large sea
level changes we think it's the Remo
belies a ssin of fine-grained sediments
by the deep circulation
okay I'm getting to the second proxy
I have no feedback about my timing am i
doing okay just give me a little high
sign to speed it up if you I'm gonna
talk about the sedimentary protactinium
thorium now so the first told us I think
a little bit about dynamics more about
the chemistry on the bottom predict
inium thorium we think has the
possibility to tell us something about
you can think of it as the mean
residence time of deep waters in the
Atlantic Basin and it's it's the same
contrasting chemical behavior that we
take advantage of uranium in all its
isotopic forms is highly soluble
therefore it's well mixed has a long
residence time in the ocean decays with
a predictable and well-known rate to
thorium which is removed on the
timescale of a decade and protactinium
which is the daughter product of the
less abundant uranium-235 but there are
very very few places on the earth where
uranium 235 and 238 don't occur in the
same ratio and the deep ocean is not one
of them they're both well mixed in the
deep ocean so these two are produced at
a known and essentially constant ratio
but protactinium-233 so it has a
resonance time that might be a century
or even two that's time enough for
lateral motions of seawater to move
product NM around and those lateral
motions can be disorganized eddy
diffusivity if you will or organized
advection with the deep water either way
the time scale is such that promote of
protactinium is more possible than
thorium
so what we can do is look at the
sedimentary ratio of the two and compare
that to the known production ratio and
the idea is if there is an organized
flow as there is today in the deep
Atlantic more of the protactinium can be
swept away and the observation is that
in the North Atlantic more than 90
percent of the forum can be accounted
for it's being buried in the North
Atlantic and about half of the
protactinium is missing it's going
somewhere and that somewhere almost
certainly is the southern ocean which
has high ratios of protactinium to sort
maybe the one number worth remembering
within this talk if not after the talk
is the production ratio of those two
this is an activity ratio that they're
produced in seawater its 0.093 when the
burial ratio is lower than that it means
protactinium is in deficit when the
burial ratio is higher as it is in the
southern ocean
that means protactinium is being
exported from somewhere else
and within the Atlantic Basin they're
more or less in balance protactinium
missing from the North Atlantic is being
buried in the south in the southern
ocean that behavior can be used to model
the resonance time of the seawater
within the basin and I'm not going to
try to put a number on that but the
scaling is such that the residence time
is longer when the protactinium thorium
ratio is higher is nearer the production
ratio and the residence time of water
must be lower when more protactinium is
being exported and the ratio is lower
and across roughly the same interval of
the last ice age these are the product
tinium thorium ratios so you can see
that at the times when it is warm in the
northern hemisphere the ratios are lower
and these ratios reach numbers there
they're going down but they reach
numbers graphically anyway that rival
the modern observation that half the
protactinium is missing and that's in
the context of an overturning
circulation that's moving maybe 20 spur
drops of North Atlantic deep water out
of the basin those appear to be the
strongest overturning during the cold
times that ratio increases and in some
cases even rivals the production those
intervals suggest longer residence time
of the seawater and greater burial of
pros actinium locally on the seafloor
now there there are potential other ways
to get values that look like this and
they mostly have to do with the
scavenging intensity and that's
partially why I'm using multiple proxies
here because scavenging intensity is not
going to effect some of the other ratios
but the most effective scavenger for
pros actinium is biogenic opal biogenic
oval doesn't discriminate between
thorium and protactinium and scavenges
them both and at the bermuda rise there
is at most a very weak relationship
between biogenic opal flux and pros
actinium thorium in other parts of the
ocean and other intervals of time
there's a very very strong relationship
of these two but across how any of the
definition of these intervals or the
mean there's at most a weak relationship
and so we think that scavenging is not
the dominant process here the relative
strength of the lateral transport which
we think is related to circulation
versus scavenging that's the control
okay the third of the proxies is a water
mass tracer it's not so much to do with
the dynamics it's not so much to do with
particles scavenging and lateral motion
it's the signature of the water mass and
simply put there is a relationship
between nutrient content and stable
carbon isotopes in deep waters it's an
inverse relationship as phosphate or
nitrate is utilized because of the
fractionation the selection of carbon-12
by photosynthetic organisms of the
conscious selection but the the
preferential uptake of carbon-12 by
those organisms essentially all organic
matter is depleted in carbon 13 and so
when surface waters use up all the
nutrients they become highly enriched
the water that's left behind becomes
highly enriched in Delsea 30 and that
prevails in the waters that sink as
North Atlantic deep water and to a much
lesser extent holds for southern source
water so that in the modern ocean in the
modern Atlantic this is the distribution
of carbon isotopes high here in the
north the end member for North Atlantic
deep water is on the order of
per mil in Dell c13 southern source
waters are much lower and can get to
zero and even negative and in a series
of measurements in sediment cores from
along the western margin Korean oboes
showed that at the last ice age the
distribution was quite different from
the modern that this northern source
water filled less of the basin and was
only the dominant source in the upper
two or two and a half kilometers whereas
the deep basin was filled from the south
now remember these are the southern
waters are the same ones that I showed
had lower carbonate ion and were more
corrosive in the modern ocean yes
okay I'll spend a couple of minutes on
this thanks for asking that question
it could be a longer topic but the
control there is when the waters is
subducted at either end of the planet
have its nutrients has its nutrient
content been fully utilized and in the
North Atlantic deep water
the answer is closer to yes and in
southern source waters whether they're
derived directly along the Antarctic
margin or by the upwelling of water that
includes North Atlantic deep water that
has had remineralized material the
upwelling in the southern ocean rapid
cooling and sinking in either case for
southern source waters the answer is
much less yes and more like only
partially so that means that southern
source waters by the predominant
mechanisms in the world today that might
or might not have been different in the
past but I would say are likely to have
been the same Antarctica was still there
the wind was still blowing over the
circumpolar current the physics that
drive the changes today still prevailed
nutrient utilization in the northern
source waters leads to higher del c-13
in part because it has spent longer in
the euphotic zone if you think of it as
a conveyor where waters move through the
South Atlantic across the tropics up the
Gulf Stream into the Norwegian Current
you know that's almost certainly the
wrong way to think about it but
conceptually that's a long residence
time at the sea surface waters that form
around Antarctica first of all up well
with high nutrient content they may be
shielded from the atmosphere by sea ice
they may gain their density properties
subsurface by
brine rejection of ice formation around
the the Antarctic margin or they may
come up to the surface cool rapidly and
sink in all of those cases they haven't
had a long residence time at the sea
surface so you know that would be maybe
a shorter way to describe it
and we don't know that those things
prevailed in the past but there are
reasons to think that they might have
okay what I was saying is that in the
modern ocean these southern source
waters are more corrosive and it's for
the same reason that they have lower del
c-13 they have higher nutrient content
they have more importantly higher
dissolved co2 and unless they have
equivalently higher alkalinity they're
going to have a lower dissolved
carbonate ion so this scenario would
suggest less preservation in the North
Atlantic and this scenario in the modern
suggests greater preservation and those
carbonate cycles that we saw we
interpret as shifts back and forth
between these two and this is what those
carbon isotopes look like when the
product tinium thorium ratios shift to
lower values the carbon isotopes shift
to higher values it's consistent with
greater flushing from the north at the
same time as nutrient depleted
Hidell c13 high carbonate ion in other
words calcium carbonate preserving
waters all of these proxies are telling
a coherent consistent story then during
the cold intervals here these smaller
ones but for example this Henryk event
interval these ratios approach the
production ratio of pros actinium and
thorium and at a time when the dell c13
reaches a minimum which in this case is
minus point zero point six now there's a
whole ocean change in carbon isotopes so
we have we can't scale these exactly to
the modern but these are dramatically
lower values even correcting for the
whole ocean transfer of carbon from the
terrestrial biosphere to the ocean
there's no water that looks like that in
the Atlantic Ocean today these look like
great incursions from the south and then
what happens immediately afterwards is
greater export of product inium greater
preservation of calcium carbonate and
higher del c-13 and this next figure
summarizes all of that
although shockingly poorly on the big
screen you can all come up and look at
my computer one by one because you'll
see the difference here is some clarity
of the labeling but more importantly
maybe some shading at each of these cold
intervals this is the one I was just
talking about right that then here here
here in any case I'll trust you to guide
your own eye our argument is that the
calcium carbonate content is driven by
changes in calcium carbonate flux and
remember our preferred interpretation of
that is not big changes in productivity
in the subtropical gyre there big
changes in preservation and those
coincide with the presence at depth
of high c13 water that in the modern
ocean forms in the north and has lower
nutrient content lower dissolved co2 and
those are times here where the
protactinium thorium ratio decreases
that's the top panel that suggests
shorter residence time of the northern
waters they're less stagnant they're
moving laterally and our preferred
interpretation is that they're moving
laterally in a systematic flow from
north to south as part of the amok now
this is the summary of what I've just
been talking about I'm going to show
briefly three snippets of evidence that
are separate from this and are either
related or follow on the first is what I
promised at the beginning with the
permission of crystal booze art and
waste divided ice core community I'm
going to show some of their unpublished
results from the ice core in West
Antarctica that has an Antarctic signal
but higher accumulation rate that allow
really detailed comparison with
Greenland and the same structure or the
same approach to that alignment prevails
here and that is the fact that methane
concentrations are well mixed throughout
the atmosphere and therefore methane in
Antarctic ice cores and methane and
Greenland's have to vary at the same
time but the structure of that variation
looks very much like the northern
hemisphere so these things can dig the
methane structure allows the cores to be
aligned and you see this same pattern
here now sorry time is moving from left
to right
because the waste divided ice core
community and others in paler climates
are thinking maybe we have to
communicate with the rest of the world
not just with each other there are some
who resists that but I think
communication is a good thing but once
you flip your minds around to where you
were you're normal and maybe when you
walked in you can see that same pattern
rapid warming in the north this is the
rapid warming in the north cooling in
Antarctica and in there careful analysis
of the phasing of those things they
arrive at this conclusion
Greenland's changes first and then a
century or two later Antarctica changes
that's both for the warming in the north
which is then followed by cooling in the
south and cooling in the north which is
then followed by warming in the south
and I would argue that this is
consistent with those changes in the
Atlantic Meridian overturning
circulation playing a role in the
bipolar connection because the timescale
of that mixing in the Atlantic Ocean is
on the order of a couple of centuries so
the communication of that signal down
the length of the Atlantic might begin
initially but it would be fully realized
after a couple of centuries
I think that there there's something
like three to five year nominal you know
they don't know the age of each piece of
ice and what's most important here is
not the true chronological uncertainty
but the relative uncertainty in the
sequence but I think the nominal
resolution is is some few years because
they take chunks of ice and envision I
suppose this is jumping around a little
bit but this is that last Heinrich event
during the last deglaciation where we've
now generated and compiled something
like a depth transect down the length of
the Atlantic and the relevant transect
is actually all in the North Atlantic
and the implication here is that from
the last glacial maximum which had
something of a diminished overturning
into the Heinrich event that occurred
during the deglaciation the overturning
circulation in the Atlantic diminished
and that signature is felt throughout
the water column and this was the most
recent you know that's not quite right
this is the most reason but one events
that the waste divided community looked
at this is the so-called Heinrich event
one and there's one more event after
this the so-called Younger Dryas and we
don't have this kind of data set there
but this is additional evidence I would
say that the overturning circulation
played a role during the D glaciation
and then the last question is if maybe
this is a big if if you believe that
these changes punctuated the entire last
glaciation
and the deglaciation have they been
occurring through the hala sea is are
these kind of dramatic changes part of
the climate system at all time scales
and we're just beginning to explore this
but the initial evidence at least at the
resolution that we've currently achieved
is that we don't find evidence for such
dramatic changes in the previous figure
this is the deep western basin this is
actually very near the deep western
boundary and there's not any signal of
strong oscillation there's a deficit in
protactinium at all times
it looks like the export of product
inium from the north atlantic has
continued throughout the Holocene so
I'll wrap up by saying that the changes
in the amok accompanied the abrupt
climate changes during the last ice age
has been postulated for some time there
is some evidence existing that would
support that we would say that we
provide further evidence for that again
and again the deep Atlantic repeatedly
filled with the equivalent of North
Atlantic deep water that was vigorously
produced and when that happened dramatic
warming ensued in the north and cooling
began in the south although the ice core
records now tell us that those things
were in synchronous that the warming
happens in the north and some century or
two later cooling began in the south so
I would agree with this concept of a
bipolar seesaw and suggest a change in
the spelling that's all thank you